.
Gabrielle Proulx.
- En Europe, on connaît
la première canicule de
la saison, avec un mercure qui
devrait dépasser les 30° dans
les 40° par endroits.
À N, , , , , , , , , , , , , , u
plus tôt qu'à l'habitude.
- àààà, entre 800 et
1000 personnes sur la journée,
donc c'est énorme par rapportoù.
- Une affluence qui rappelle
la fraîcheur demeurent bel et
bien un enjeu de santé publiqu
BRIGITTE BOURGUIGNON, ministre
de la Santé de la France
- Des personnes âgées,
enceintes, des nourrissons,
parlons aussi de la
au travail.
de mise pour éviter de revivre
les effets de la canicule
de 2003, qui avait fait
plus de 15 000 morts.
FRÉDÉRIC NATHAN, prévisionniste
- Les climatologues nous
le disent et puis on le voit
concrètement, ces vagues
de chaleur sont appelées
Avant, si on veut,
il y a quelques décennies,
ça se passait en juillet
et en août principaleme
Nations unies, lui, déclare
qu'il est encoreblblblble
d'inverser la spirale de
la sécheresse, associée aux
changements climatiques.
Or, la sécheresse,
elle semble installée en Espagne
depuis le mois de mai, où on a
enregistré les tpupupupupupupups
les 100 dernières années.
Trois feux de forêt font rage
dans la région de la Catalogne.
Le plus dévastateur d'entre
eux, aurait brûlé entre 5000
et 7000 hectares au Nord-Ouest.
À Brighton, au Royaume-Uni,
les Anglais s'apprêtent à
de l'année. Pour certains,
il y a quelque chose
qui ne tourne pas rond.
Alors que pouasasasasasasasasan
de relaxer un peu.
Ici Gabrielululululx,
Radio-Canada, Montréa